(light symphonic music)
- [TC] To be happy and healthy, they
need to be able to run.
And maybe, just maybe, this
is my role in this world
is to provide that for them.
My name is TC Wait, and I am a dog musher.
(plucky instrumental music)
Rescuing these dogs and giving them a home
is really important.
We have right now 23 sled
dogs on the property.
We kind of have this motley
crew of scratch and dent
sort of dogs that have
come to us from a variety
of different places.
We have a group that have been rescued.
We've got some from a shelter.
We've got some retired racing sled dogs
that are living out their
golden years with us.
In my mind it's a second
chance for these dogs.
Are we ready to harness?
- Yeah.
(piano music)
(dogs bark)
- Huskies love to pull a sled.
It keeps them active, it
keeps their mind focused.
This is what they were bred
to do over generations,
even though they are older
or maybe they can't keep up
with a race team, they
still love to do it.
You don't have to be the prima ballerina
in order to enjoy dance.
The way that we make this
work is we go back and forth
between Colorado and Alaska.
So in the summertimes, we're
down south in Colorado,
and hold down jobs and
save all that we can
during the summer so
that we can put it away
towards the winter.
We've managed to transport 21
to 22 dogs over three thousand
miles each way, twice a year.
(serene instrumental music)
I've got friends and family,
they might not understand
our crazy little life but they understand
that we're doing good
things for these dogs.
There is nothing like
experiencing a dog team in action.
You're literally dropped into
this snow globe of wilderness
that you can explore
and you get to do it
with your best friends.
It just makes my heart sing.